[Applause]
joss whedon was going to give us a gift
and that gift was superman with a
mustache
and none of us get to see it unless we
put it
back on him we could make a little
trailer to pitch warner brothers on this
idea
this video is sponsored by razer nvidia
studio we are giving away a free razer
blade pro 17 so stay tuned to find out
how you can win it
i couldn't sleep last night i was
thinking about how there's
footage of superman with a mustache
that we never got to see that footage
does exist it exists somewhere in wp's
archives
the pickup shots they did for joss
whedon's original vision of superman
with a mustache
somebody at wb was like you know what
i'm just gonna meddle in the movie
and take his mustache out these
producers are always messing with the
director's vision it's a it's a
classic tale i think it's a disservice
to the world that wb decided to take his
mustache out
joss whedon was going to give us a gift
and that gift was superman with a
mustache
and now none of us get to see it unless
we
put it back on him that's a lot of
responsibility
well like they say with great
um
[Music]
great power great power great power
that's from the original batman
when his parents get shot and they're
bleeding out of the opera yeah the joke
returns somebody goes
with great responsibility comes great
power and then batman's like i'm batman
there were moments where i was suited
booted and mustachioed yes
i want to show the world the beauty of
having a mustache particularly
the beauty of having a mustache on such
a beautiful person as
henry cavill what a beautiful world we
could be in we will visualize that world
for you in this video
we're gonna delve into some technology
here we're gonna show you guys how to
put a mustache on people
and with this video i think we can
create enough demand
for wb to release the mustache cut
it's the right thing to do they've
already they've already did the whole
snyder cut so what's one more cut guys
come on
it's easy it just takes a few minutes
you just bring in the footage in
premiere and you just
export i love deep faking stuff
i love ai it's such a crazy new world of
visual effects i'm going to use it in
this video
if you saw our luke skywalker deep fake
i mean you have an idea of where we can
get these days with the fidelity of
these things
that's like a military-grade industrial
quality
deep fakes and you can't really do that
at least on a puny computer
but i need to be training this over the
weekend and bringing home one of these
giant machines can be a pain in the butt
but we just got some razor blade pro 17s
and they have an rtx 3080 inside
except i had got an extra one with a
razer core x which is an external gpu
box that has an rtx 3090 in it
so you're saying this laptop has a 30 90
attached to it
yes i'm saying this laptop has a 30 to
90 attached to it not in it
it has a 3080 in it the 30 90 is the
only gpu that can do deep fakes good
enough for what we want to achieve here
sorry i'm nerd alert real hard here but
deep fakes require a ton of ram
uh specifically vram which is only on
your gpu
and up until like this year everybody's
like ah you don't need a lot of vram
what do you need vram for and there was
like ai and they're like oh
and then they actually put a bunch of
vram on gpus now it's really cool it's
great we're turning the corner of
technology
laptop actually has 16 gigs of vram
which is still super impressive
with this crazy setup using the razer
and the
core x i can be running a deep fake at
the quality of what we did with the luke
skywalker one and i can do it for my
home i can do it over the weekend
and i can just bring it with me back to
work think about it we're using a razor
blade
not to shave a mustache but to grow one
i need to grab a bunch of elements of
superman without the mustache i need to
grab a bunch of elements of handkerchief
with the mustache
and then i'm going to start training it
over this weekend for my house
all right so it is the weekend i'm
having ivy record this
and i have fired up this deep fake on
this laptop
and it's looking really good so this is
the razer blade pro 17.
i want you to know that we are going to
give away this laptop
so you have to follow us on instagram at
corridor digital for the details on the
giveaway
now i want to hype you up a little bit i
want to get you guys excited about this
laptop because what are you guys going
to win it
has an 8 core intel i7 processor it has
a geforce
rtx 3080 in it these nvidia studio
laptops are built for content creators
you can punch out renders uber fast from
cinema 4d and blender with 16 gigabytes
of vram
and you can do 4k editing in premiere
pro or real-time color grading in
davinci resolve
and with nvidia studio drivers which
have been optimized for the creative
software that we use you get added gpu
acceleration
and reliable performance it's a really
nice computer also it's got thunderbolt
ports it's got usb 3.0
it's got a 4k 120 hertz touchscreen
display
and the whole body is built out of
milled aluminum
so it is a tough machine basically this
computer
can be a mobile desktop replacement
razer doesn't just make the razer blade
pro 17. they have the razer blade 15 and
the razer blade stealth 13. both of
which are also super powerful and if you
guys want to learn more you can go to
razer.com or you can take one of these
for test drive at a razer store
if there's one near you and the giveaway
more details on that will be on our
instagram
at corridor digital so stay tuned all
right now back to the mustaches
so i've been uh training this computer
on how to make mustaches
all weekend so this is uh remember that
really janky
shot they opened justice league with
back in the day i deep faked
the mustache version of henry cavill
trained it on regular
superman version of henry cavill
oh my god at all everything you see here
is train from
his look in mission impossible which is
interesting because in mission
impossible he's doing certain facial
expressions as his character
he's always going like this he's always
furthering his down a little bit
so even like like right here he's still
scaling just a little bit
the janky smiles and things like that in
justice league
he never moves his mouth like that like
you can really see his mouth structure
when you're looking at a deep pig
remember how janky the smile is here
the deep thing is doing its best here's
the original
look at the difference in how his lips
are structured like his bottom lip
doesn't go over his teeth
who smiles like that
this one looks really good this dude's
great that looks really good
it just needs a little contrast bump and
it's there with a little masking that's
totally usable
but that looks i mean this is fantastic
i kind of
love superman with a mustache i wouldn't
be mad if in a future movie he had a
mustache
so yeah there it is wow this stuff is
always so cool i'm like yeah
whatever and then we do it i'm like this
is kind of crazy
so peter and myself have devised a
pipeline that is developed exclusively
for putting mustaches onto
henry cavill it's actually first of its
kind yep so we figured we'd do an
interactive demonstration of our new
mustache technology
where people could join us art is fun
when everybody gets to participate so
we're going to demonstrate
interactive mustache visual effects
what the heck what the heck
i don't have a mustache dude friend
i know you can't grow one
[Music]
this is how it is this is how it's
supposed to be mission impossible is
just one type of mustache but we don't
need to stop there
what if you could have any mustache you
wanted on intercapital so this is the uh
the station where you
build the mustache i guess i guess i'll
demonstrate here i mean somebody shouted
out pencil mustache
it's a very sloppy pencil mustache
it's supposed to be like riding you on a
yosemite sam wait nika with the nose
[Laughter]
[Music]
we need to take this seriously yeah
we're trying to we're trying to
demonstrate to warner brothers that if
they want to put the mustache back in
we have a pipeline developed for it
[Music]
that was terrifying what are you doing
three tiny mustaches
i'm gonna give him a disguise
i mean this is basically clark kent's
actual disguise griffin
if you can give me a handle bar i need
like a little bar
real looking handle really can handle
all the way down
the handlebar mustache is not the one
that goes down your face like lily hogan
yeah the handlebar mustache is the one
that's on your forehead
oh no kidding yeah so wait what is the
whole hogan stash what is the biker
stash
horseshoe the horses yeah i want that
hulk hogan horseshoe stash that's what
i'm looking for
is that wizard hulk hogan right there oh
my god
you shall not pass brother
i got it fitting pretty good here bro
oh my god dude oh my god
did you just give him the limp biscuit
he's so rad dude the reason we gather
everybody here so we could actually
check the actual mission possible
mustache make sure that's the right one
peter i do have one in there called
[Music]
impossible
that's like a 910 stash right there i
feel like this is the right call that's
definitely the right call
it's the best looking one out of all of
them he is working it
like there's no tomorrow all right case
closed captioning not
[Applause]
realistic what available you wanted
henry kevin to have a long waving
mustache you can't do that with a deep
fake
yet so i wanted to bring some of these
shots into blender and see if i could
push the limits of these mustache shots
we got stroopwafel's fist coming through
here trying to punch henry cavill
and missing there's an opportunity for a
mustache here some flowing mustache
coming out
the fist going through it he's trying to
punch superman's mustache off but
superman's mustache is not having it so
how could we
put a mustache in this shot well first
we have to have something to put the
mustache on and so i went on
trustyolcgtrader.com and i downloaded a
3d model of henry cavill's head
unfortunately the model didn't have a
mustache so we're gonna have to put that
on later
what a beautiful man honestly even in
grayscale just the curvature of his head
so i just took this head model and i
crappily went frame by frame tracking it
onto henry cavill's head just so it's in
the right position so we can simulate
the mustache and it'll follow along with
his head from there
we take our hair tools and blender and
we grow some hairs out of henry kevin's
face and then we take our little blender
scissors and cut over the lip we do not
want a walrus or a horse shoe
or anything animal related we want this
to be a strictly
bar mustache so after we groom the hair
it's time to simulate it thankfully this
computer is
super freaking fast this is simulating
as i'm playing this right here
lightning fast it's simulating a
thousand hairs right now
which is not a small amount of hairs we
need that fist coming through and kind
of causing some
air to be displaced moving the hair out
of the way
so we have our mustache floating amongst
the cg stars
but we want it to look like it's stuck
to henry cavill's face what we're going
to do is we're going to take that henry
cavill 3d model and set it to be a
shadow catcher so you can't actually see
the model
but it's receiving the shadows from
things around it to make it look like
the mustache is casting a shadow onto
mark hamill
henry cavill hairy cattle my god
oh that is silly and with that we are
ready to render freaking rendered this
shot when i went out to launch rendered
in like
20 minutes at like 300 samples 1080p
yeah i'm super happy with how this
turned out especially given that i
turned the shot around in like an hour
ridiculous on a laptop pretty sweet
so i finished my deep fake i've done all
the compositing i've done the masking
this is the best i can get right now
with this deep fake
all right let's take a look i know you
oh damn that looks good the lighting
this i think it is in like 400 000
iterations training for about four days
and also
i used a pre-trained model that we had
done for luke skywalker so that helps me
get a little boost in time otherwise
i'd be looking at probably about eight
days if i did in four
and it's interesting flipping back and
forth look at his nose see how his nose
shifts in position and also look at his
teeth see how his teeth
like stick down more in the cg face and
the lip shape is a little bit different
that works pretty well it doesn't look
like a real mustache like i don't see
any individual hairs
but the shading of it in the placement
like it works
i would love to see a shot of superman
with his natural mustache
we can only truly tell if we're active
or not if warner brothers releases the
mustache cut
now that we have all these shots we
could make a little trailer to pitch
warner brothers on this idea and maybe
kind of get everybody excited about it
hashtag release the mustache cut
imagine you this could be your superman
right here look look how handsome
we've proven with the power of unity and
community that we can get them to remake
a movie once let's do it again
release the mustache cut release the
mustache cut
superman can we ask you some questions
what's the best thing about planet
[Music]
or earth it a dream or was it something
more than what it seemed
the enemy is here clark
[Music]
we don't have time
team needs clark and what is clark need
bruce no you have no idea what kind of
power you're dealing with but this is
science beyond our limits
the way we're gonna stop him is by using
his power this power
against him i agree
this is crazy oh what now it's crazy
your goatee is okay but i'm a big fan of
[Music]
mustache
all right so we're going to upload just
the mustache cut to instagram at quarter
digital
you guys can take it you can post it you
copy paste it everywhere you know please
give us a shout out hashtag release the
mustache cut
riled the troops the foot soldiers you
want to see it in front of the eyes the
warner brothers executives and henry
cavill himself
that was definitely a funny looking
superman